Hello everyone. It's December 13,
2022. We're in active bookstream.
Number 1.2 on the book
governing continuous transformation.
Off to Bleu. Hi everyone.
We are the Active Coherence Institute,
participatory online learning institute
that is learning, practicing and
thinking about applied active inference.
You can reach us here at all of our
media links. This is a recorded and an
archived live stream, so please provide
us with feedback so we can improve upon
our work. All backgrounds and
perspectives are welcome here and we
will be following good video etiquette
for live streams. Hopefully get in
touch if you want to participate either
in this book stream or the zero
contextualization streams or in another
Livestream or maybe in the discussion
stream. You can reach us
always@active.org or by email.
Okay, so here we are, bookstream 1.2.
The action will go through the Bookmap
and the roadmap, the keywords and the
claims, and we'll be continuing the
discussion of Governing Continuous
Transformation. So I don't know if we
want to just maybe mention a couple of
things, one or two things that we're
excited to discuss more today or learn
more about from this section of the
book. Tyler, is there anything that
stood out for you specifically or if
maybe you want to give an introduction
and then maybe say one or two words
about the book, the chapter? Yeah,
sure. So I'm Tyler. I work more on the
applied side of thinking about
governance, organizational design. Both
work in the Dow tooling space and also
protocol design also works in a lot of
like corporate settings or as a strategy
consultant. I think for today what I'm
excited about is that I went to business
school, something that I hear a lot
about some of these organizational
design framework that Bijan references
in the book. But it's really interesting
to compare that directly to free energy
governance and compare contrast to see
where the gaps are. So I'm excited about
exploring that more today. What about
you, Bleu? I am really excited to
kind of link and so I'll do this right
up in the very beginning, but to link
what we have talked about in Active
Coherence Lab Institute over the last
couple of years about biological
organization and hierarchical
information flow in biological systems.
I'm excited to connect that to how that
works in an organization. As I was
reading the book, that was something
that stood out to me as something that's
maybe necessary for a more elaborate
discussion of the text. Cool.
Daniel, anything? All the
comments at the Road Map, but I'm
Daniel, I'm a researcher in California
and just looking forward to this
discussion. Cool, thanks.
Okay, so here we are at the book map.
We are in Chapter two, sensing Sense
Making and Strategic Renewal. And the
roadmap for today is just two sections.
These were structured actually by the
author strategic cognitive scientist and
sense making. And the second section is
strategic renewal. Did you want to make
a comment here. Daniel at the roadmap.
Not yet. Thank you. Okay,
so lots of keywords in today's
discussion. So we'll just jump right in
and hopefully we put them in an order
that aligns with the order in the book
and included some commentary and claims
from the text as well. All right. So,
Tyler, do you want to read this first
part of the abstract? Sure.
Sense making form one utary act together
consider non operational cognitive
medicaidability or dynamic capability.
There's no sensing without sense making
and vice versa. And there is no
organizational sense making in the
absence of a clearly defined, deep
existential corporate purpose.
Generally, the processes of top down,
bottom up, hypothesis testing,
prediction error minimization rather
than top down heuristic simplification
are grabbing the path, navigating a
discontinuous world. There's
neurosciences predictive coding that
allows us to take management researches,
strategic cognition, and more
specifically connected to structure and
cognitive niche. Step further to provide
a more complete and practice relevant
framework for applying sensing and sense
making in the concept of strategic
renewal. I want to take the next part.
Sure. Thanks. Daniel, do you want to
read this Parr? No. Okay, I'll do it.
Effectively, sensing and sense making
are empowered by the circular causality
of top down knowledge structures,
prediction, action, prediction,
hypotheses and guesses, and bottom up
stimuli data stemming from resource
markets by default. Uncertainty and
complexity are subjective concepts that
are consistently deployed in management
research as objectively determined
environment. Sensing and sensemaking are
nonsensical in the absence of having set
the firm's purpose and context in the
first place. Once we define sensing,
sense making, and strategic renewal in
form of action, centric circular
causality linking purpose, prediction
models, predictions, and prediction
error minimization, the new logic of
strategic renewal emerges. Dynamically
connecting structure, hierarchy,
cognition, and capabilities.
I just really wanted to bring this in
here. We're talking here about top down
and bottom up. And I know that there's
management styles and structures that
are associated with top down and bottom
up like management styles, but I really
wanted to bring up this paper, the
Information Theory of Individuality by
David Krakauer and colleagues at the
Santa Fe Institute. And I bring this up
because really they try to define what
is an individual, even in a biological
system, an individual, we have more or
just as many cells inside of our body
that are not human as we do cells that
are human, right? But if you were to
take all of those non human cells out of
my body, I would not be the same person.
I would not function optimally at all.
So I'm more maybe than just what is my
DNA, I'm a colony. Not necessarily.
Like, I'm one organism. I'm many
organisms to function appropriately.
And so really, these guys tried to
define how you contain an
individual, like, what is worthy of this
Markov blanket. Like, we talk about the
Markov blanket as the boundary between
internal and external. But where do you
put that? Am I drawing it around my
human cells? Between my human cells and
my non human cells? That doesn't really
make sense, right? So they talk in this
paper a lot about and they do it in a
hierarchical way, which is why the
biological levels of organization are
here, because you can define an
individual at the level of a cell or a
tissue or an organism, population,
community, and so forth. And this even
applies to organizations like a company.
So here what is critical to be defined
as an individual is this bi directional
information flow. I think that this
paper is very elegant and great. So you
have to have information flowing top
down, and you also have to have
information flowing bottom up to be
worthy of a Markov blanket and
considered an individual in this paper.
And so I really just kind of wanted to
bring that in because they talk about
Bijan, talks a lot about how you need
this bottom up and top down, and they
have to work together. And he talks
about that a lot in the book for a firm
to persist. And so really it's necessary
for anything to persist, you have to
have that bi directional information
flow to earn your Markov blanket, so to
speak. I just wanted to kind of bring
that up here before we jump into the
additional context. Talking about top
down and bottom up in the book. Did you
guys have any comments here? Daniel yes,
but I was going to suggest that The
Roadmap was a quote from the abstract
subjective concepts pragmatically
applied, which I think deals with a lot
of informational concepts. And then like
you brought up, if you define self
spatially or genetically, you're going
to get some boundaries which may be
relevant in certain situations, but also
might give a misleading or Attial view
of the total system. And then the
challenge is when we move to this
informational or statistical theory of
nested Selves, then organizations and
their niches can have many different
looking causes and components. So it's
very challenging and it's not the chart,
it's not the computer access chart.
It's something that's somehow different.
And I think that will be relevant to
pull out what is being described and
what should people's consideration be?
What do we actually gain by saying that
systems are nested, which isn't a novel
insight?
Yeah, that's great. And then also in
talking about that bi directional
information flow, there's a certain
amount of salience that has to be there.
Also, like information can be flowing
both directions, but if the information
is irrelevant, then that's going to not
be the cause for perseverance. Right?
Okay, cool. Okay, so here we are.
Strategic cognition, sensing and sense
making and just and early quote from
this chapter. Do you want to read this?
Tyler? Is that okay?
All right. Strategy initiation and
formulation defined as a complex
activity consisting of scanning. Sense
making and strategic decision making are
at the heart of the firm's collective
interpretive power, emphasizing its core
capabilities, timely and accuracy
reading of expected environmental
change, and the corresponding need for
resource reconfiguration in pursuit of
the adaptation. Cool.
Thank you. Okay, so strategic cognition,
they use the definition presented
in this paper, the Cognitive Perspective
in Strategy and Integrated Review, and
they referenced this paper quite a bit.
So I just pulled out this diagram of
strategic cognition and pulled up the
definition that was used in this paper.
So they say strategic cognition is
discussed in terms of its constituents,
structure and process. By structure we
refer to the relatively stable
characteristics and repeated patterns of
behavior and by process to the cognitive
activities taking place in
organizations. Just to
note on that, the focus in this
book is on kind of a
certain type of corporation with a board
of directors, for example, which is an
important category. This I'm also just
imagining someone who is navigating
spatially as part of working in a taxi
service. Also, strategic cognition is
coming into play, though the wording
might be framed a little differently,
but it's similar questions about sense
making and just different
implementations of different kinds of
organizations. And I wonder how
strategy in terms of this kind of
strategic cognition is related to the
systems engineering approach. Is it
align with that or maybe not? That's
something to be interesting to know more
about. Do you have any comments here,
Tyler? Yeah, that's actually something
that to build on Daniel's point, like
how specific what Bijan is talking about
is to board specifically versus other
organizational structures. And just like
a comment on that, my initial feelings
on so far where we are in the book is
that it's really not. And I'm not seeing
why we need to reduce the scope of just,
like, organizations that have boards,
especially since most companies I've
been in, a lot of the important decision
making is really happening at the level
of really more of the
executives and the C suite. And Bijan
might argue like, hey, that's actually a
problem, it should be more coming from
an active board. But it's kind of
interesting to see where the limits of
what Pajama is talking about and how
specific is it to a specific kind of
organizational structure. Or another
angle is in the body. The decisions are
being made in a distributed, nested way.
And so that kind of organization, I
think we'll read on to find, will have
resonance with this. However, who should
the strategic communication and cutting
edge research on the strategy,
governance, upstream decision making.
There's a very certain audience I think
it makes sense to communicate that to.
And also this is the threads being
linked for a first time in a
dissertation style book. And I could
imagine different kinds of presentations
and implementations being presented
differently, not necessarily like an
academic published dissertation.
And that leads me to wonder, perhaps
strategic cognition can take place at
many levels in a hierarchical system.
Like maybe an individual, like a project
or a team is doing strategic cognition
on the execution of their goals and
tasks. And that happens at the level of
the individual and the team and the
project and the department and then the
firm and then the board. So perhaps it
occurs in several places. When I've been
reading board one of the Johnson's
board, I read that as like Council, and
that's my interpretation of that. And
that can happen at many levels as well.
Funny. Like when you say counsel, I
think attorney. Why do we have lawyers
involved? I mean, Council has been like
high counsel, supreme counsel.
All right, awesome. Okay, so sensing
I pulled this out to Tyler's protests.
I wanted to just maybe talk a little bit
about sensing and sense making and
talk a little bit about them separately.
But they are sensing and sensing and
sensing and sense making form one
unitary act and together can be
considered a non operational cognitive,
metacapability or dynamics capability.
And this reminds me of the time that I
asked Karl about like when I'm sensing,
what am I sensing? Like if I am I
sensing like when I look at a red
balloon, am I sensing red balloon or am
I sensing like 700 nanometer
wavelength of light and round oval
shape? Like what is actually being
perceived via the senses?
And Karl answered me, he said, red
balloon, go away from the red light and
go more toward the red balloon.
That answer really says, okay, there
actually is not sensing without sense
making. Like they are inextricably
linked because if I'm actually sensing
red balloon, then I'm going beyond what
my eyes see or like what my nose smells
or whatever. Okay. And effectively
sensing and sense making is a form of
organizational learning, action centric
hypothesis testing that connects the
individual level with that of the firm.
Do you guys have any comments here? We
can move on to sense making or stay in
sense making maybe.
All right, Tyler, this is yours. All
right. Sense making. So purpose goal
directed in this so the world's models
underlying prediction model is
fundamental to sensing and sense making.
So dissonance is a function of a preset
goal generating predictions and
submitting those predictions to
continuum error. Minimization sense
making models are constantly adjusted
through error and deviation clearing
feedback loops, coupling top down
predictions and bottom up Simuli and
circular causality. The sole objective
in minimizing prediction errors and
surprise, ie. Free energy.
Fundamentally, sensemaking is about
designing noticing systems. And so what
I really liked from the paper that is
actually from Wake, I'm not sure if I'm
pronouncing that right, is sense making
is about how people deal with situations
where there are too many or too few
meanings. And this is something that
I've experienced a lot, especially in
like startup context. Like you could
think of it and they're actually kind of
the same situation, too many or too few
meanings. Like if you're in a startup
and you're trying to figure out what you
do next, your strategic directions are
kind of infinite because you haven't
really built that many. So there's like
all these things, directions you can go,
things you're hearing in the ecosystem
like, oh look, we did this, look, we did
this and that all could be meaningful.
But at the same time it all collapses
into like, what are we actually doing?
Are we even building anything right now?
What's the point of any of this? And so
a lot of how that kind of shows up in
your, like, for example, in a health
context that show up in the body is kind
of like illness or this feeling of
agitation and anxiety. And you kind of
have that same embodied feeling both in
yourself and in the organization of
like, hey, what we're doing isn't
working. We're having all these
communication kind of issues where
there are breakdowns, where you're not
receiving what I'm telling you the
information I'm telling you about
problem isn't being received correctly
and acted upon. And this like boils up
to becoming a bigger issue to where
something needs to happen and some
action needs to be taken. And so it's
really like the social process, not
something that's like the CEO being
like, wow, let me go in here and figure
out the root issue like a plumber would
and then tell the organization what
happened. But it's more of this kind of
feeling of agitation that happens
throughout the organization and through
this social process being like, what is
going on? What are we doing? People
getting increasingly blustered.
Something is birthed in that process and
something that actually had like a
personal realization when I was reading
this chapter because I used to work as a
strategy consultant and strategy
consultant, what I kind of realized
about that job is that it's purely about
sense making. So a lot of times people
think of strategy consultants as like,
oh, you're doing like a complicated
quantitative analysis. You give that to
the board of directors, they make a
decision super top down. But actually
where we spent most of our time on was
socialization, like kind of talking to
people, like kind of knowing when we
went into the organization, like,
roughly what was going on in a certain
way. We collect data, kept talking to
people. But even when we were pretty
sure we had the answer, most of the job
was actually framing and communication
and talking to a bunch of people and
using the language that they use and
making sure that there is a shared
narrative between everyone. And so that
was where the real work is. And I was
like, oh, that's interesting.
Management consultants are professional
sense makers. And I think a lot of times
a lot of organizations are actually
embedding management consultants within
the organization as a way of sense
making, as a capability that an
organization would have. And so an
example of something I had as a
agreement consultant where you kind of
feel this dissonance was like, I work
for a lot like health insurance
companies. And so health disturbance
companies were having this problem where
at least in the US. Skyrocketing
Healthcare Costa and if you're a health
insurance company, you're basically a
payment processor. And so you don't
really have any levers to fix that. And
so there is this issue of like, okay,
well, we need training. Costa but we
don't have any levers to do that. And so
what that means is that you have to
become more of, like, a care manager to
some extent. And that is a totally
different way of textualizing who you
are, both on the organization level and
on the individual level of like, what is
my purpose here in this role in this
organization? What this organization
trying to do? And getting to the care
management side totally needs to shift
that. And so that shows up in the
organization. That's a lot of
dissonance, a lot of angst, and also,
like, a lot of pain. And it ends
up meaning that both the communication
needs to change, but also this
individual needs to change themselves
and how they relate to that
organization. And so that's why I like
this cartoon of like, I've been
restructured a lot of times. It's like
you have to recontextualize yourself
while so the organization is
recontextualizing what it's trying to
do. So, yeah, I'll leave it
there. Daniel and Lewis, do you have
anything to add on the slide? That's
very insightful and it reminds me of the
two ways that the entities can reduce
free energy by changing their mind and
changing the world through action. And
this is an approach where we can
describe that process happening at
multiple nested and interacted levels.
And even if the niche changed around
one, the world would be different. The
regime of attention would be different,
the action perception loop would be
different, and that would, at the very
least, induce anxiety and uncertainty.
Cognitive niche. It's really interesting
what you added, and. I just love your
cartoon.
Okay, so here is a claim
from the book, from the chapter. On a
more operational level, sense making
very effectiveness is shaped by three
critical dimensions. First, the clarity
of a timeless corporate purpose.
Second, a dissonance centric quest for
and optimization of filtering anomalies
as anomalies become shared sensibleness
should become stronger. And C, an an
activist worldview I e environment is
not exogenously predetermined, but is
enacted through the social and action
centric construction of shared meaning.
Let's talk about disturbance a little
bit.
Going back to this quote, unless you
guys have comments here. No? Okay, so
fundamentally firm level sensing and
sense making grounded in dissonance
theory are a social process rather than
a singular activity dedicated to
detecting anomalies and I think this
goes back to what Tyler was actually
just talking about. But I looked up,
like the theory and this is the citation
that Bijan used. And in this text,
Festinger says in short, I'm proposing
the dissonance, that is, the existence
of non fitting relations among cognition
is a motivating factor in its own right.
By the term cognition here and in the
remainder of the book, I mean any
knowledge, opinion or belief about the
environment, oneself or one's behavior.
Cognitive dissonance can be seen as an
antecedent condition which leads to
activity oriented toward dissonance
reduction, just as hunger leads to
activity oriented toward hunger
reduction. It is a very different
motivation from what psychologists are
used to dealing with, but as we shall
see, nonetheless powerful.
And so when we talk about sensing and
sense making being grounded in
dissonance theory, this is something
Tyler and I had discussed offline back
channel. We were talking about
dissonance theory. And what we're
interpreting this to mean here is that
it is this disjoint activity,
like a mismatch between maybe, like,
individual and firm level cognition or
firm level cognition and societal
expectations or and way there's a gap
that causes like a kind of discomfort
that needs to then be filled. But I
would be excited to hear maybe Bijan
talk more about how it's grounded in
dissonance theory just
because it was kind of unclear from the
text, like what exactly that might mean.
But if you guys have any comments here
Daniel yeah. Active inference
lab. We might think about dissonance as
being related to a divergence, like a KL
divergence. And so dissonance isn't
a state of exception and kind of a
binary switch. There's always some non
zero level of emergence between
expectation and incoming sensory data,
if only because the generative model is
coarse grained. So in the decimal
points, the world always is going to be
somewhat surprising, or at least
evolution in terms of surprise. So
again, instead of centering, for
example, absolute value attainment and
then seeing uncertainty as a secondary
characteristic, we use divergence based
statistics to incorporate this idea of
dissonance or divergence driven behavior
and put that at the center of the
imperative for action.
Yeah, I interpreted the John's
Dissonance theory as a way of bridging
both the individual cognition to the
social cognition and had a feeling of
anxiety manifest in and organization.
And so I think Disney's theory, at least
in this quote, might be referring to the
individual specifically and how that
individual but anxiety of like, hey, I
thought I was going to get a promotion
this year. I didn't get a promotion this
year, something is wrong, or like, hey,
I worked really hard on this feature.
It didn't increase conversions in the
way I thought it would. That feels bad.
That's not motivating for me. Right?
That's like on the individual level.
But then you can there's another way you
can interpret that dissonance on the
more of, like a social level as a way
and more of a social cognition.
Cool. All right. Non uniformity.
Tyler all right.
It's critical that the environment,
throughput listening to what wants to
emerge, is neither logic nor goal
trapped, but open to non uniformity. In
fact, the throughput of non uniformity
is a measure of firm survivability.
Uncertainty and surprise are not to be
avoided, but to be minimized through
action hypothesis testing, centric
engagement with the world as the
underlying world model. Consequently,
and generatively gains an informational
edge. And so we talked about this a
little bit during the last bookstream,
but a lot of leaders want to imagine
that they're, like, slowly ironing out
non uniformity and that you're creating
this perfect organizational design. And
it's actually kind of funny. There's
this trap that a lot of leaders get
into, and I've actually gone into this
myself, where it's kind of like utopia
design, almost. Actually, it's exactly
the same thing as Utopia design, where
you're like, I'm going to have this
model where all these problems I
perceive in the world I'm just going to
fix by just like top down, just like God
mode figuring it out and then everything
is going to be there and we're not have
to worry about anything anymore. So we
create and then invariably you
create a new design, two weeks, and it
works for like a week and people are
excited about it. And then, like, you
start seeing kind of ripples, ant the
edge. You start, like, trying to patch
things up and then it like all
disintegrates. And then, like, I think a
lot of leaders are like, oh, well,
like, you know, people we have the wrong
people. People aren't, you know,
following process, like I want them to,
right? And it gets really frustrating.
But I think even when it goes well,
it's just like you were missing out on
kind of, like, how generative
that non uniformity can be and where
basically, like, if people are too rigid
in their process, you're, you know,
you're not carving out space for
anything new.
The way that John talks about non
uniformity in this case is that you
minimize it through kind of action
oriented hypothesis testing. You're not
like, wallowing in this uncertainty.
There's a way that you can capture that
and take ownership over uncertainty and
use it for something that's really
beautiful and productive. For example,
I've had jobs where I was a product
analyst and I work for this consumer
logistics company where we go into
people's homes and pack up all of their
things. So it's like a very complicated
job, right? And so we would figure
things out, like, okay, wow, our times
for this kind of job in the city are
going up a lot. And we would see that in
the data and we're like, wow, this is
really inefficient. And that we would
like, that manifest itself as some kind
of anxiety or dissonance. And then we
would start, we do analysis and we'd
be like, oh, it's this kind of job.
It's this kind of job, this kind of
furniture. Then you talk to people to
talk to some of these movers and you
find out, oh, they don't have the right
equipment on this. They don't have this
kind of wrench on these particular jobs.
They're like, that's interesting. Then
you socialize that information, figure
out from operations that that wrench
isn't consistently being returned and
they're actually losing a lot of their
equipment to be able to do that job.
Then you find out from other operational
leaders that they're not being funded
appropriately. They don't have
discretional spending to be able to
actually pay for those kinds of that
kind of equipment. Right. So it's like
through that anxiety, you kind of are
action oriented and could figure out,
like, hey, this is not something that
the situation isn't totally screwed. We
can actually keep moving forward and
testing, figuring out what's going on
and taking action accordingly. That
makes me think of pain and soreness and
redness in the body. Like,
signals have to propagate in order for
things to change. And that could be in
an allostatic or an anticipatory or in
a reactive or in a traumatized way from
the organism's perspective. But the only
way that we're going to find out about
it is through this kind of, like,
active perception. Individuals or nested
levels above them making an action
oriented decision to sense out different
information and control attention,
which is actually seen as a policy
selection over cognitive states.
Sorry, my mouth was sticky. I am
also reminded of biological systems,
but maybe for a different reason. So in
biology, non uniformity is critical to
existence. Like, you have a system of
equilibrium in a biological system,
that's death. This non uniformity. And I
think he even brings it up as
critical. I don't know if I quoted it
here, but he brings it up as critical to
survival. You have to have non
uniformity. If everything's the same.
It's like dull, bored.
It's so important to have variety.
Variety is the spice of life. Right?
Okay, cool. All right. Purpose. So
purpose and goal directedness. I e. The
forward model, underlying prediction
model is fundamental to sensing and
sense making. And like, this is the
forward model underlying model. So I
just wanted to point that out that
there's some nestedness going on here.
Dissonance is a function of a preset
goal. Generating predictions and
submitting those predictions to
continuous error minimization.
Environmental sensing and sense making
are nonsensical in the absence of having
set the firm's existential purpose in
the first place. Purpose, not strategy,
is the reason an organization exists.
Its definition and articulation must be
top management's first responsibility.
And this reminds me of our agreement
organization in the Active Inference
Institute. Like, what is the purpose of
the institute? And just trying to kind
of outline and. Highlight these key
things. We can't have a strategy without
having a goal. What is that
strategy trying to achieve? What is the
point, right? If you guys have comments
here too, that'd be awesome. Just that
is this meant to be a sentence in one
language or another language? Even in
the same language or a formal language?
It will mean different things to
different people. It will be associated
with different envelopes and portfolios
of risk and positive or negative
consequences, also deemed positive and
negative by a different worldview and
contingent upon all these unknown
unknowns. So I think amidst that is
where we can explore a lot of
interesting experiences, I'm sure, in
what has worked and what hasn't worked
in the applied settings, and then also
start to synthesize it with the research
on cognitive science and organizational
cognition. And that's, I think, what
this book is about, like moving beyond
just recognizing that complexity and
starting to apply active inference and
propose free energy governance as an
approach to step in here and be useful
as well as grounded. Yeah, just to add
on that, I'm curious if John ever
gets to a point in the book where he
really gives some guidelines for
thinking through how to design purpose
more explicitly. Because journalists
chaos done extremely poorly, even in
major corporations where they're like,
our purpose is like bringing smiles to
our consumers or something. Like
something just like super big ambiguity
actually doesn't really help you at all.
It's more of actually like a branding
exercise and more of like a corporate
social responsibility, maybe. Not really
anything about purpose. And when purpose
is done well, it's really more like you
guys might disagree with this
definition, but I think it's kind of
more like a heuristic. It's like a
decision rule of like, we do this and
not this. And it's a way of collapsing
information and just being like, let's
not think through everything we could
possibly be doing right now. Like, we
already decided this. This is what we're
doing, and it's a way to not think about
things too. And so I found this to
be especially important in decentralized
context as well. And I think this is
kind of what free energy governance is
getting towards, where you have more
bottoms up stimuli that you're
processing and changing these top down
models. And it's really important in
that context because you can't be
managing everybody really intensely
saying this is exactly what you have to
do, but rather you have to give a
decision rule that a decentralized group
of people can use independently. So
especially as we get into more of the
free energy governance kind of world,
purpose is super important. But like
Daniel touched on, it's not always
totally clear what a good purpose even
looks like. And I hope John has a very
crisp answer later on for what good
purpose is. So here I
am, the non business person, and Tyler,
you said you don't read business books
but I've read more than I ever wanted to
read. My own
little startup side venture. But I read
Jim Collins good to great book and he
really talks about purposes really as
defining what you do and what you don't
do. It kind of affronted me. He talks
about the Fox versus the hedgehog. The
Fox does lots of things very well. He's
very clever and can do many things. And
the hedgehog only has one thing. They do
one thing, that's it. They roll up into
a ball, right. That's all a hedgehog
ever does. And so in this Fox hedgehog
analogy, like as a company, he says you
want to be a hedgehog. And I'm like,
but I want to do so many different
things. But really that having
especially when I think about a
decentralized thing, we do one thing.
Like I don't know. He talked about many
different companies but Wells Fargo as a
bank was a good example. We are creating
the best bank in the United States of
America. We're never banking outside.
Maybe it started regionally and expanded
a little bit or even Southwest. We are
only going to fly in the Southwest.
They just defined one thing that they
were good at that they could just be
better than everybody else at and just
ran with that. And that is kind of like
one of the defining factors of a great
company in his view. Yeah, exactly. To
build on that a little bit. It's been a
long time since I read it to great, but
Jim Collins is kind of like the
prototypical top down or what some would
call an orange style of management where
it's very achievement oriented. It's
very much about the CEO as being the
hero, forcing their way and telling the
organization what to do and focusing
everybody really intensely. And so when
you talk about the Fox and the hedgehog,
it's interesting. He says you want to be
the hedgehog because usually when I hear
people talk about Fox and the hedgehog
he's like, you don't want to be the
hedgehog. Like forcing everything into
your narrow world model. And so I
think when he says be the hedgehog,
it's really coming from this top down
perspective and it's really not getting
into the free energy governance model of
like where ideally you want to be both
the Fox and the hedgehog. You really
want to have a unified world model that
you're like, hey, this world model is
like not true by the way. We all know
that this is subject to change and we're
going to be actively changing this, but
we all have to be on the same page. And
so we're going to have this somewhat
arbitrary belief of what our purpose is
that we're going to continuously evolve
over time in a fox like manner. And so
that's a really hard thing to
communicate and it's like very subtle
and I've tried to communicate this in
the past often ineffectively.
And so I'm really curious if there's
ways to better combine that fox and
hedgehog model.
Now we're spinning out on a tangent but
I just have to say, I don't know, like I
get the whole fox thing. I am very much
like aligned mentally with how a fox
type of behavior because I'm just like
oh swirl, let me go chase that. But the
hedgehog thing I was thinking like okay,
do you really want to be a fox and a
hedgehog or do you want to be like
multiple hedgehogs? I had this vision of
dropping water on the hedgehog like the
little gremlins and you drop the water
and then they multiply and then you have
a little field of hedgehogs that are all
doing many different things in a very
great way but all siloed and they're one
little thing. Okay, we have to go on or
we can talk about gremlins all day long.
So for heuristics, I mean this actually
fits Hinton purpose because you could
think of purpose as a heuristic and I'm
not sure if John would agree with that
but that's how I think about it. And so
read at least his definition was
cognitive. Heuristics are a form of
cognitive simplification or rules of
thumb and tools empower the human mind.
What the poet John Keats called negative
capability, the ability to survive and
thrive in uncertainty. And so
yeah, there's just a way of collapsing
information overload and finding a way
forward despite not having the ability
to process everything at the same time.
But then John goes on later to say that
heuristics are fundamentally anchor in
the world Dean with environmental
adaptation rather than enactment. So
resolving uncertainty is rather treated
as a matter of adaptation to and
exogenously determined game. This book
rejects environmental adaptation as a
viable survival strategy in a
perpetually discontinuous oneshot
interactions environment.
And so to just illustrate this a little
bit, obviously I think we could all
understand like a heuristic may not be
very good, you could use the wrong
heuristic and how do you know? But just
like to make this more concrete about
how heuristics can be confusing is that
here are two really common heuristics
force financial planning, especially in
the context of startups. So one is
called Default alive and this was from
Paul Graham, he's the founder of
Combinator and so he says okay, a
company should cut costs such that if
you assume constant revenue growth the
company is going to make it a
profitability with the money it has
left. And so that totally makes sense
especially in a startup context where
extreme uncertainty. But then there's
like another decision rule which is more
about expected value. So a company
should choose the financial decision
with the highest expected value,
expected pay off of outcome X and
outcome times the likelihood of the
outcome. And so these aren't necessarily
incompatible. They can be complexity to
each other but they could tell you to do
very different things. Especially if
like an expected value of like hey, we
can crater the business right now is
like a 10% likelihood but we can also
90% likely but 10% likelihood we make
100 billion dollar company, right? And
so that would lead you to do a different
thing than default alive. And so a lot
of times business leaders are juggling
both of these at the same time and not
necessarily realizing that they are
contradictory heuristics and that there
are limits to their heuristic. So yeah,
I'll leave it there. May I say a couple
of other things that he says to you that
simple. Heuristics can outperform more
complicated ones as well. And it's,
like, actually not even clear on
organizational level how effective
heuristics are, because a lot of times
when they do studies on heuristic with
individuals where everything is, there
are not other intelligent actors who are
making anticipations of that Europe
strategy. Whereas in a business
setting, there are. And so to take a
very simple example of this with design
there for a long time was this movement
of the heuristic for design was like oh,
everything needs to be super legible and
clean. And you would use like helvetica
16 point really. We want this to be
clear and we want information hierarchy
and that matters far and above
everything else. But then the problem is
that everyone was doing that, and it got
really monotonous. And so the actual
optimal strategy in that case was to
design something totally wacky and
insane. And so over the last three
years, there was like this, especially
with the web three, just, like, absurd
looked like they were like GeoCities
pages from the 90s where it looked awful
and it was not accessible and it was
gross, but it was really interesting to
look at. And they were using fonts that
are totally unreadable, but it was
interesting, and it was this competitive
situation where the obvious heuristic
but in a competitive situation made the
optimal strategy doing the opposite of
that heuristic. Oh,
just a few notes, there's so many great
points. One is the game theory.
Although bar problem where there's a bar
and you want to go if it's under half
full, but dot one half full, it's not
fun, you can't get a drink and it turns
out that that's like an unwinnable game.
Because if you go well, if it was busy
yesterday or if it was busy three nights
ago, all decision rules if you just hold
to them, get adapted around and
I think then that's a very interesting
light to reject environmental adaptation
as a strategy position of the book
because I think adapting to the
environment sounds like something
biological. It sounds like something
that would be successful
organizationally. And then I think that
will also lead us to some discussions of
how does the free energy minimization
generative transcend the default alive
expected value dialectic?
All right, so this is an acronym for
Volatility, uncertainty, Complexity,
and Ambiguity. Starts with some
background on this right now, by the
way. So I'm just
reading a quote. This is actually a full
disclosure from my aunt, who's a
leadership and organizational design
consultant. She wrote this post called
Explore and Vogue Territory, and I
really liked how she framed this. Where
most of us in the west were trained in
the professional model that prize
expertise. Today, being an expert and a
specialist is not enough. And worse, it
can make you part of the problem,
because today we are dealing with the
frontiers of humanity, a place where no
one has been and no one could possibly
be a content expert. And so what I
really like about this is that we're
entering this world that is increasingly
volatile, increasingly ambiguous, but at
the same time, that really runs up
against how we're individually motivated
as professionals, where a lot of us
really want to get good ant a thing and
have mastery. And it really requires
handling this uncertainty complexity
that volatility is like a personal
discipline as well as an organizational
discipline. As far as that personal
resilience, handling that uncertainty
and complexity is what is going to make
the organization resilient. And that's
actually quite hard to build. And it's a
very rare skill set and
a lot of it's about one. And I hope you
like how this graph frame this, of,
like, how well can you predict your
action and how much do you know about
the situation? And on both of those
axis, it's becoming increasingly so that
you know very little about the
situation. You really can't predict your
actions, and the ability for
expertise to really navigate through
that is much less effective, and it's
much more about cross function
collaboration. Daniel Bleu do you want
to take anything on that?
Cool. Okay, I'm going to read this claim
from the book. Generative processes of
top down, bottom up hypothesis testing I
e. Prediction error minimization rather
than top down, rule based simplification
are guiding the path to navigating a
discontinuous world. I'm just going to
read these yellow parts. In fact,
rather team uncertainty. In fact,
heuristics rather Team Uncertainty,
heuristics reinforce dominant logics in
the form of pattern recognition and tend
to disregard dissonant bottom up stimuli
as noise. In fact, heuristics may
reinforce the phenomenon of deliberate
ignorance and tame curiosity's.
Information enriching drive as a
foundation for prediction error
minimization. I really liked this quote
from the book and thought that it kind
of maybe sums up the argument against
heuristics and also this top down,
bottom up circular causality that we've
been discussing through the chapter.
Daniel a little bit uncertain about
heuristics for information enrichment
and epistemic drive cannot be a
heuristic. If so, would that close
the loop. So that's like, the reward
function? I mean, we've had this
discussion many times, like the
epistemic and pragmatic value when you
knock out one side of the equation,
what do you have left? So, yeah, can
your heuristic merely be info sampling?
I think that that's probably fair, but
yeah, a subtle technical detail,
probably. Tyler cognitive maps.
All right. Cognitive maps are closely
related to heuristics and can be
considered a form of visualizing sense
making in form of graphic
representations that locate people in
relation to their information
environments. Maps provide a frame of
reference for what is known and what is
believed. So I've
actually made a lot of cognitive maps
myself on various consulting projects.
And what's kind of funny about cognitive
maps is that they're actually really
useful to make as the person who is
making them. As you go through the
process of making a cognitive map, you
feel like, I understand the complexity
of this organization pretty well at this
point, and I can actually hold it all in
my mind at one time. But the problem
with that is that there's two problems.
One is that no one has understands your
cognitive map at all. It's only useful
to you. And then the other problem is
that it basically immediately becomes
outdated and does not reflect how the
organization actually works. And so even
like a month, two months later, it's
like completely useless, even to
yourself. John has a good
quote of this where he really says that
this cognitive map isn't really useful
for the purposes of free energy
governance. So he says, cognitive
mapping is representative of the
deterministic view of the world, akin to
a physical cause and effect chain, and
she should be considered rather ants
clocked in the face of discontinuous
market environments. So, yeah,
it's really not something that you're
going to be able to fully map out how
governance works or how an organization
works. This is actually something that
I've been thinking a lot about for the
past couple of months in the context of
dows, of like, can you model the flow of
value and power completely within an
organization as code? And I think what
John would say is probably not it's not
fully like this deterministic model of
cause and effects. It's really something
more of a social process that's a little
bit more ambiguity and fluffy and hard
to nail down. Daniel Bleu, do you have
anything to add here? So,
on the one hand, I don't know cognitive
maps. Like, when I was taught about them
in college, they made no sense to me. I
hated them. I was like, this is the
dumbest thing I've ever heard of. But
then when you get into process flow in
writing code and in system design, they
kind of make sense, like an experimental
design chart. So I don't know, I'm back
and forth on the can you read your own
cognitive map? Sometimes I would argue
that if you can't read your own
cognitive map that it's not a good one.
How about that?
Okay. Claim. Okay.
It is neuroscience's predictive coding
that allows us to take management
researches, sense making, perspective,
as well as nexus of structure and
cognition. One step further to provide a
more complete and relevant framework
force applying sensing and sense making
in the concept of strategic renewal.
Effectively, sensing and sense making
are empowered by the circular causality
between top down knowledge structures,
prediction models, predictions,
hypotheses and guesses, and bottom up
stimuli data stemming from resource
markets. I just thought it was important
to include this claim here. I feel like
it sums up a lot of what is written in
this chapter. Okay, so we'll talk
a little bit about active reasoning.
And this picture on the left shows like
inductive reasoning, which is like,
when you have a specific observation,
you come to a general conclusion about
that specific observation. Like,
if you see three men wearing white
shirts in a room, and then
you might say, like, oh, all the men
wear white shirts, but it might just be
a coincidence, right? And then like
deductive reasoning, where you have a
general rule and you come to a specific
conclusion, like, you know, all the men
have to be wearing white shirts in this
situation. And so you conclude that the
men in this room will be wearing white
shirts. So that's like a deductive
reasoning. And then you have this
abductive reasoning where you have this
incomplete observation where you see
some of the men in the room wearing
white shirts and you don't know anything
about the rules. You have this
incomplete observation and you make your
best prediction.
I guess some percentage of the men here
like to wear white or something like
that. So this incomplete observation
coming to this best prediction, I
probably did a horrible job at specific
examples, but those were just like,
sorry, off the top of my head. So that's
like this reasoning logic and a quote
from the text abductive reasoning
usually begins with a surprising
observation or experience. This is what
shatters our habit and motivates us to
create a hypothesis that might resolve
the anomaly. Abduction is an inferential
procedure in which we create a
conjecture that if it were,
would make the surprising anomaly part
of our normal understanding of the
world. So I liked this idea of linking
action to surprise. And I just wanted to
point out the Livestream
number 47 about active coherence and
abduction. And we discussed more than
one paper in this live stream. So just
to read a quick quote from this specific
paper. This paper. It's Piataran.
I probably butchered that. And Majid
Beni, and I think Majid was on that
stream with us. And this paper says,
the focus is on the allegiance between
the nomenclatures of active and active
inference as the proper place to begin
reaching at the wider target. The paper
outlines key concept elements involved
in a naturalistic rendering of Pierce's
late semiotic and logical notion of
abductive reasoning and targeting a
cognitive biological model of abduction
which preserves the functional integrity
of an organism and fulfills the
existential imperative for living beings
evidence of existence. And this paper
was awesome. Like totally mind blowing.
And I can't do it justice in like the 5
minutes or whatever time we have here.
So if you want to learn more about
abduction and the Relationship Active
Inference lab, I suggest go check out
this live stream or read this paper.
Unless you guys have comments here, you
can move on forward. Yes. One comment on
that is that I found it really
challenging often to in an
organizational context to toggle between
inductive deductive and abductive
reasoning where it's like a lot of times
people get confused which kind of
reasoning you're actually using. And if
you do something that is kind of more
adaptive, like, hey, here's what I'm
seeing, here's my best guess, throwing
things, ant the wall. Then you get
tracking these things like, well, how do
you really know that's true? And you're
like, yeah, that's the point. I don't
know that's true. But we're really just
trying to like this is a creative act
we're doing together of trying to come
up with some hypothesis. This is a
really specialized skill set and it's
like quite hard and funny. In the book,
I don't think we pulled this quote out.
I almost did, but I was like, how do you
be but like, Bijan. I don't know if he's
quoting someone else or he just says
objective reasoning is like, any
hypothesis is good enough, whatever.
It's just kind of like, I don't know,
shooting arrows in the dark. It kind of
made it sound like that. But there
actually can be quite a bit of art and
science to abductive reasoning.
Okay, cool. So John lays out a few
different frameworks for thinking about
collective sense making and specifically
how you connect different levels of the
hierarchy together. Like sense making,
it one of the individual and leveling
that up through organizational sense
making. And so he talks about these like
six different models of collective sense
making and wasn't necessarily saying
like, hey, I am fully behind each of one
of these, but he's more just talking
about prior work and how to think about
the gaps of how they line up to free
energy governance. So let's go through
each one of them. The four I model.
So the four eye models, this is the
intuitive interpreting, integrating,
and institutionalizing. And so this is
really thinking about how sensing flows
through the individual level and then
bubbles up through different levels of
socialization up and through
institutionalization. So Crossings for
iModel, intuitive interpreting,
integrating, and Institutionalizing as
applied to the context of strategic
renewal provides a framework for the
process of transmorphing individual
sensing and sense making cognition to
firm level strategic action, intuiting
and interpreting. A hypothesis starts at
the individual level and subsequently
the interpretation, sense making process
becomes socialized, integrated and
institutionalized at the firm level.
And so this whole process is
goal directed. It's not just taking
bombs of stimuli and then somehow
magically transforming it into
institutional processes. It is really
goal directed and hypothesis driven of
really inactive and saying, hey, this is
what we believe about the world and
seeing this is actually the case.
And I think the John has an interesting
point about the score. I model that a
lot of times organizations really don't
view themselves as being active creators
of their world are really especially
when you coherence up like the board
view themselves as more passive
receptacles of information. And so this
whole process of sense making from the
individual level to the organizational
level is really like an active process
driven especially driven by the board.
Bleu or Daniel, do you have anything to
add here?
All right, tension based view. So,
attention based view. This is another
model that is similarly connecting both
the individual level of cognition to the
institutional level. It just has like a
different spit on it and different
emphasis. And so in this model,
the idea is that you need attention to
make decisions, like, you need to put
some focus and energy to make a
decision, but individuals and
consequently firms, have limited
attention. So this is just like the
fundamental constraint on your ability
to Markov decision is that you just
don't have the time or energy to devote
to every single decision. And so
your individual cognition is
constrained. And because your individual
cognition is constrained, so your social
cognition and like, that social
cognition is shaped by different
factors. That is like, social factors,
cultural factors, economic factors,
and that social cognition, those forces
that shape like, situational context
that shape your social cognition, those
manifests and are institutionalized in
the organizational cognition and that
is, like, rules the positions, the
players and the resources. So if you
guys are familiar with Eleanor Ostrom's
model of thinking about kind of how
common resource organizations develop,
it's kind of like the same exact
framework that she uses. So this
is very consistent with free energy
governance, though it doesn't really
capture that active process of reality
construction. It's much more about just
like, thinking about attention and how
that bubbles up to different levels of
the hierarchy. Bleu.
Daniel. Anything out here? All right.
Dynamic capability view. So the
aim of dynamic capabilities research is
ambitious to understand how firms can
sustain a competitive advantage by
responding to and creating environment
change. This is from Help At, who is one
of the main components of this type of
Dynamic Capability View. They also go on
to say that dynamic capabilities are the
capacity of an organization to
purposefully create, extend and modify
its resource base. So this is very
consistent with how I learned about
organizational design and evolution in
a business school. It's much more about
like, hey, we have these kinds of
resources kind of like the sellers of
the data model almost like we have these
resources and these constraints in our
environment and this is like how we can
extend that resource base and grow over
time. And it has a little more like a
deterministic bent to it and
it's about like how you survive in a
quickly changing environment. So in that
sense it's like similar to free energy
governance but it's really more about
strategic change. It's not really about
the individual cognition. It doesn't
really talk much about individual
cognition at all. So it's like an
interesting theoretical framework but
it's not really as
embodied as free energy governance and
it's missing that relationship to the
individual. Bleu Daniel,
anything to add here? All right,
so OKRs are objectives and key results.
So the idea here is that you have a gain
so at every single level of the
hierarchy. So let's say that your
company top level of the hierarchy will
just use this examples on the slide.
You're the head of the brand, you want
to get 1000 new sign ups, right? That is
your objective is increasing brand
activations and the key result like the
quantitative way you measure that is get
1000 new sign ups, right? So that's at
the top level of the organization and
then in each level of the hierarchy
below that you have the sub components
that would need to be true to get 1000
new sign ups, right? So the things that
would need to be true to get 1000 new
sign ups are that one you have to on the
head of content, you have to get your
click through rate above some threshold,
implement 1012 new mediums post old or
new content. On the partnership side you
have to get 10,000 event registers by
some date, right?
So it's basically a way of thinking
about like how goals cascade from the
top level of the organization and filter
down through the other level.
Sorry about that. Very persistent.
And so this is actually really popular
in a like especially like the tech
world. This is pioneered by like John
Dor. Larry Page wrote this book about
measure called Measure What Matters and
it's about like a quantum tattoo way of
thinking about organizational design and
goal setting. And so I've actually done
this a lot at different organizations
and it can be powerful and I think the
genre really likes it. He says OKRs have
proven to be invaluable and dynamic tool
to foster formal exchanges at the field
level of resource markets approximating
self organization. Because each level of
the hierarchy has the responsibility for
themselves to set their own OKR that
aligns with the next level of the
hierarchy, right? So it can be really
dynamic and have that self
organizing quality. However, a problem
with it, and this is not something that
John brought up, this is something from
my own experience is that especially in
a startup context, things are moving so
quickly that OKRs very often
become outdated pretty much. Like
immediately. And so you'll set an OKR
for a quarter and then you're a month
down the line and so much has changed,
the context is so different that this
OKR obviously doesn't matter anymore and
that's a huge problem. And so you need
some way of changing your OKRs
dynamically. But the problem is that
OKRs take a lot of work to set up and to
socialize and to measure and so
then you really don't have the resources
necessarily to do that and that is a
huge challenge. There's also huge issues
with doing OKRs and that it's like some
version of good ants law where your
measure becomes a target, it ceases to
be a good measure. Whereas these
different levels of the organization can
over optimize for some arbitrary metric
that they need to get a promotion which
sometimes that can be aligned with the
organization, but in quickly changing
environments it can become quickly not
aligned with what the organization
actually needs. So there's a lot
of pushback for OKRs right now it's
unclear. I think there's probably some
formulation of OKRs that's more dynamic
and more responsive to bottom up stimuli
but they can
be really hard to operationalize but
theoretically amazing way of connecting
different levels of the communication.
Christ all right, different levels of
the organization. All right,
let's go to the next one. Collaborative
intelligence. So the drive for self
organizing mechanisms gradually moved
from employee empowerment and cognitive
intelligence in form of crowdsourcing
deploying the journey of the power of
information technologies to tap into the
collective knowledge base to
collaborative intelligence. CQ
emphasizing the need for a shift in the
leadership model from having all the
answers to raising the right questions.
As digital tools are increasingly
deployed to enable goal directed
intelligence deliberations and
distributed multi intelligence systems.
And so to think about what this actually
means, like in practice oftentimes it's
not the case where it's like you have
some really huge robust system where
every person in the organization is
seamlessly sharing their insights and
their data. That's not really how it
works. It much more works that it's like
you have specialized sense makers within
the organization and consistent ways of
processing data and sharing that data.
So, for example, you'll have, like, an
It team. They have, like,
a central data warehouse where they put
all the data together, they clean it and
sanitize it in a consistent way. And
then you have embedded kind of sense
makers, like kind of consultants or
analysts at different levels of the
organization processing that data,
sharing insights with each other,
socializing across the organization.
And that tends to be kind of like how
it's generally structured, especially a
lot of tech companies.
All right, and open strategy is kind of
an extension of that. It's like the
extreme extension of collaborative
intelligence. So open strategy is
categorically different traditional top
level strategizing and qualitatively
different from bottom up strategizing.
So open strategy is unique in its
overall transparency, wide,
inclusiveness, and central use of social
it to effectively enable mass
participation. In summary, open strategy
is rather project centric rather than a
coherent new strategy governance
framework. The very limitations
transpiring through the various case
studies suggest that open strategy is
likely to battle with schwarmers three
enemies or inner voices of resistance
the voice of judgment, voice of
cynicism, and the voice of fear. So open
Strategy is this kind of idea where it's
like, the strategy can emerge through
this kind of like, bottoms up
information processing. If we all have
the information available to us, it
wouldn't be purely on top down decision
maker for synthesizing all of this, but
rather we could all do that together and
something more robust will emerge
through that process. And this is like
especially a popular concept like Teal
organizations or Holocracy. That kind of
decision making is like the gold
standard for how it should happen.
Though he brought some interesting use
cases about things like IBM, I think
it's Pepsi, a few other different use
cases where their experience with this
is mixed. And when he says this is a
project centric rather than a coherent
use strategy governance framework, it's
easy to do this more in a project
setting because you can think about what
the relevant pieces of information are
and who all the stakeholders are that
you want to involve. But to do that
dynamically means that you're
continuously bringing in new
information, changing a new stakeholder,
finding a new decision making processes
between those stakeholders that's super
hard to do on a continuous basis rather
than, like a limited scope project
basis. So it's kind of unclear how
to make up a strategy work over a long
indefinite period of time.
Yeah. Bleu Daniel one thing to add here
yeah, just like one last point here is
that I really like My brought up the
voice of the inner voices of resistance,
the voice of judgment, the voice of
cynicism, and the voice of fear. And
that's really been kind of this feeling
I've had as I've been reading this book
of, like, yes, this way of integrating
top down and bottom up stimuli together
sounds great, and it's totally the right
way to do it. But sometimes the reality
of being an organization is that you're
dealing with people's personal fear and
that really holds you back from being
able to dynamically. Chang Kim people
want stability, people want mastery.
People want things to be the way that
they were the same in the past. And
that's a very deeply, I think, human
thing. I'm not sure if that's something
that's unique about Modern organizations
and you're really going up against that
when you're trying to develop these more
like, dynamic systems of thinking about
purpose and meaning and sense making.
And to me, in my mind, that feels like
the central challenge of free energy
governance. I'm not sure if John would
agree with that, but to me that feels
like the huge hurdle you have to
overcome.
Cool. So, moving into the second
section, which is much smaller so we'll
try to be fast. Okay, there's a claim
here strategic renewal is an iterative
process of belief, action and learning
where periods of incremental adjustment,
single loop learning are broken by
bursts of revolutionary change double
loop learning. It is only when we start
expressing beliefs as probability
distributions and action as a state that
precedes perception conditioned by a
Markovian boundary intermediating the
internal and external states, all
dedicated in circular causality to
continuously optimizing the updating of
beliefs, ie. Learning, a mathematically
self consistent model emerges. So
strategic renewal he is using Dean
is using a definition put forward in
this article by Schmidt in 2018.
This book adopts across hierarchical,
capabilities driven and action centric
learning perspective in defining
strategic renewal, which is best
captured by Schmidt. Strategic renewal
involves a transformation of the firm's
core capabilities associated with
competitive advantage, concerns the
entire organization, and has
implications across organizational
levels and is essential to break past
dependence and ensure the firm's long
term survival. And another
claim he makes here is to approach
strategic renewal as an upper echelon
centric, top down only challenge is
nonsense. Given the importance of social
interactions to knowledge development
and organizational learning. We believe
that renewal can be understood best as a
system of relational or social
exchanges, which is effectively the
essence of reality construction.
Indeed, once strategic renewal is
embraced as a system of relational or
social exchanges, the need for across
hierarchical connect emerges. And I just
wanted to bring up this figure. This is
like the action perception loop from
Thinking through Other Minds a
Variational Approach to Cognition and
culture. We've had this on the live
stream before I can't remember and
didn't look up which live stream number
it was. But in this paper
they really illustrate how this
relational and social exchanges, like
interaction with the niche environment
helps us come to a mutual consensus in a
social kind of way. And so if you would
like more information there, I recommend
this paper.
Okay? And then Bijan talks about top
down versus bottom up strategic renewal.
The more dominant a top down directed
induced rather than bottom up inspired
autonomous strategic renewal process,
the more likely that critical
intelligence formed resource markets
maybe that should be from resource
markets is ignored and transient and
transformation bearing market signals
are lost. In the absence of a circular,
top down, bottom up organizational
learning, the firm may become trapped in
top leadership's dominant logics,
highly dependent on MNA joint venture
driven innovation and increasingly
disconnected from the very intelligence
the firm's field close to resource
markets beholds. Eventually financial
control, M and A and Alliancing is
likely to squeeze out strategic control
in house innovation, making the firm
potentially rather more than less
vulnerable to survival risk, as
innovation can no longer can be
generated from within the firm. Did you
guys have any comments here? Top down
versus bottom up and
financial versus strategic control.
Tyler, do you want to read this one for
me? Sure. Financial and strategic
control, respectively, correlate cue
linearly to firm performance, too little
or too much of one or the other.
Potentially entropy bound, the firm is
challenged to find an optimal balance
between external and internal innovation
to power continuous strategic renewal as
a sustainable foundation for firm
performance and survival. Indeed, the
question arises Hohwy does this balanced
financial and strategic control? And
whether the board of directors
potentially assumes critical and unique
strategic role in the process.
So yeah, I think just something to add
here too is a lot of times build
or buy. And the traditional
start wisdom of how you might balance
these two decisions of like build versus
buy is that build is we call that
strategic, right? These are the things
that are like the core and central to
your purpose. This is like the core
engine of how you create value in the
world. And buy are the things where can
mean a couple of different things. It
doesn't actually mean necessarily, it
can mean more like partnerships and
plugging into the external ecosystem.
And so that'd be like using someone
else's API for something that is not
necessarily central to you, like stripe
payment processing. Right. And so it's
this way that you can both have a
sustainable advantage while at the same
time kind of not
using your resources and your energy and
your attention for something that's not
core to who you are.
Cool. Thank you. Okay, I think
this is our final claim from the book.
Strategic renewal research is in need of
a more comprehensive framework
structurally resolving the hierarchical,
top down, bottom up learning,
disconnect cognitively embracing
environment as a matter of enactment and
in terms of capabilities, balancing
financial and strategic control as well
as exploitation and exploration. The
board of directors should be integrated
as a distinct cognitive variable into
the community of interactions. But more
importantly, the question arises whether
the board possesses the right
capabilities to be of strategic
relevance in discontinuous market
environments. I think that that's all.
So if you guys have any comments, if
not, we can move into some concluding
thoughts.
Sure. Well,
the book is subtitled reframing the
strategy governance conversation.
So I think we're getting chapter by
chapter, a clear review of the
positioning and the contribution of free
energy governance. And towards the
middle of the book, things get really
detailed with respect to the
applications of the active inference
framework. So far we've seen more of and
introductory opening salvo and a call
for need for integration above and
beyond the current existing practices,
which I think Tyler did a great job
conveying some of the real world's
strengths and weaknesses and challenges
of all these different strategies.
Yeah, I'm really excited for how
we move this into an applied setting
because kind of like combining
the fox and the hedgehog model. This is
something I've actually thought about a
dot two little success, and it's a huge
problem, especially things like OPRs
have quickly become updated. Like, how
do you create a model of the world while
simultaneously communicating? Like,
hey, this model is subject to change.
This is a work in progress that we're co
creating together and kind of
going against people's individual
resistance of not wanting change and
wanting things to be staple. I don't
have a clue of how you actually really
do that. I'm curious. I really hope that
John has good answer for that.
Awesome. Well, we'll see you guys next
week for chapter three.
Peace and enjoy the rest of your DAG
or night, wherever you might be in your
temporal existence.